it's like the beginning of the crunch
dude holy
well who is that probably what i would
call like one of the coolest vintage
anamorphic looks you can get on a budget
god
that's from all that from all that
trampoline
and you live on the top floor
so nick tell me about the ghost i was
like laying in bed it was about 3 a.m i
hear like these loud footsteps above me
just like that like
but like
directional like someone's walking it
sounded like someone straight up walking
right above my bed so i was like okay
someone's on my roof before i moved
there i lived in an apartment under
people i know i was so used to the sound
of like
and i had my friend nick crashing on my
couch i go out there in the morning and
he's like dude your neighbors like they
were really loud i don't have neighbors
creepy so he heard it too call my
landlord like did you have anything
scheduled or is there even access to the
roof he's like well actually there is a
three foot to four foot crawl space
under the roof in between your room and
the roof so what if you were to hear
something it would have been in the
crawl space
there's no easy way for someone to get
out up there without making a lot of
noise and they need a ladder and up
there what if they were already up there
what if they've been up there living in
your crawl space and they've been living
tonight i've looked thoroughly there's
no access point from my apartment
you know not until you get up in that
attic and you i'm worried i'm gonna find
a pentagram that's on the
floorboards above my bed or something
worse due to freaking well actually
that's pretty bad
we just get in there right three two one
turn on the lights someone's gonna be in
there
like you turn on the lights
what kind of equipment are we going to
bring
remember how i mentioned i have that
ladder i bought it last december and
never took it out of the box this is the
best case scenario like we have a ladder
that's brand new
am i so much no it's a telescoping
ladder
wow
hey what up sam we could absolutely use
this this is great can i try this sure
dude there's someone in your attic just
admit there's someone in your attic and
we're gonna find them tonight they're
gonna be like you got the same ladder as
me yeah i'm not superstitious i don't
believe in paranormal activity those
footsteps right above my bed was the
first time i've ever experienced
something that legit stumped me right i
would love to figure out what made that
sound what made it or at least what
didn't make it
you want an intro right now are you
ready for this you ready for this i'll
tell you i'll tell you what's going on i
got an email this week hey sam check
this out you know those crazy russian
lenses you have what if i told you i
could make them look a thousand times
better by modding them anamorphic bokehs
that's not quite what it said okay
so i've been messing with these russian
lenses more and more lately and one of
the craziest coincidences happened this
week this guy named blake emailed us to
say hey i too have been messing with
these russian lenses but i've taken it a
step further i've installed my own
anamorphic bokehs into them to create
probably what i would call like one of
the coolest vintage anamorphic looks you
can get on a budget these are like the
smallest lenses you can throw on
anything they look incredible and the
best thing is
each lens you basically can build out
for less than 200 bucks i'm going to set
up some lights here and we're going to
test out these lenses when he comes over
since they're so cheap you know like
people aren't afraid to break them and
stuff so what a lot of people do they've
been kind of taking them apart and this
is like the lightest of the months but
some people actually been taking them
apart and just sanding the entire inside
of them and then just painting them with
like spray paint and sharpie this way
they can like choose what kind of flare
they want and other miscellaneous things
whoa i just did bouquet mod the mur 1b
37 millimeter the 58 the 135 and the 85
the 85 is my favorite i really really
love the anamorphic look there's
something about it that's just it's
instantaneous like it takes you into
another world three man like man there's
just nothing out there for like cheap
anamorphic so i got my lens i removed
the actually with this one i have to
remove the front of it and you just
place an acrylic aperture disc
on the back side of the iris you can get
different sizes and for different
f-stops and stuff but for me i kind of
just been going uniformly around f4 and
you just place it in there and it's just
as simple as that ideally these lenses
work they look super cool all the mods
are compatible with the same ones we're
using and then eventually we can do them
ourselves and have super sweet vintage
anamorphic looking videos for ourselves
as well just imagine all the videos on
our youtube channel shot as if they're
in the 80s
so we're going to shoot some tests with
this also a bunch of other blake's
lenses let's see what the similarities
are do you know where jake is he's in
vacation he's been on the calendar for a
week i have to film the squarespace
integration did i remember and jake's
usually the one who does it and everyone
else is busy can you do it no come on
dude all right
actually i have an idea
oh my god
hey guys it's me jake
i now have my own personal real life
avatar to tell you more about how
squarespace has beautiful 24 7
award-winning customer service and
templates for any kind of website hey
friend how you doing man what's up jake
did you know that squarespace is
flexible for any kind of website so
whether you're an artist designer
restaurant or store squarespace is gonna
have what you need really i did not
realize this what a deal
they have beautiful award-winning
templates that the templates are
constantly updated meaning that there's
nothing to install patcher upgrade ever
did you know that i didn't know that is
this really you
yeah well i mean yeah
no i'm never coming into the studio
you can find out more by going to
squarespace.com and using the offer code
corridor crew to get
you're an artist right
yeah you're an artist hey you're an
artist i'm an artist
great that's great because squarespace
has beautiful award-winning templates
that are flexible for any kind of
website including artists who are making
videos making stores making all kinds of
things and also did you know that they
have 24 7 award-winning customer service
as well i just love walking around the
studio through my avatar it feels so
good where's my friend carmichael i've
been looking for him all day hey man
how's your juice i said i got some nuts
delicious that's our expense you can
save ten percent on your first purchase
by going to squarespace.com
corridor crew did you know that no i do
thanks jake you should feel lucky you're
welcome it's goodbye
to do a handstand
well i'll see you guys later
everyone's waiting
[Music]
it's pretty old building it was built in
i believe the early 20s
hey we're at nick's house
where where is this crawl space
what did you hear that
no i heard a door open
that happens all the time here they're
just creep clothes like did this door i
think it was this one
it's like the beginning of the crunch
dude
are you serious are we gonna get up
there do we have the right tools look
wait those are fingerprints
we got the fingerprints up there will
you call the cops if you're a scream
yeah okay
i'm expecting to go up there and be a
little creeped out because we're gonna
crawl into a very dark crawl space it's
also manifested with spiders and
roly-polies i'm excited nervously
excited spencer has been kind enough to
lend us his fleer pocket camera allows
us to get infrared heat's signature
vision
take it nice and easy don't get spooked
because there's a huge drop right there
the hand comes out i'm done really you
go
i saw a spider all right here take this
thing i don't want any spiders dripping
down oh god that's terrifying
[Music]
oh my god this is terrifying there's a
notice
that's freaking scary are you rolling on
that
what's up there dude
beams
i can't see this side just just get some
nice surveillance
there's a work light up here is it
really well there's like humiligation
notices and stuff oh my god there's so
much space up here
oh my god oh my god there's no way
anyone can stand above
yeah there is oh jeez
oh man
whoa whoa
holy moly what about over there it's
endless over there see anything [ __ ]
no white it goes around the corner is
anyone downstairs
can you give me light can somebody give
me a light i'm going to try and re-enact
what you heard are you going to make it
all the way over there mm-hmm take this
light with you who has the gopro
hey clint can you hear me
hey nick
tap the roof where are you at
can you hear that
yeah we're gonna try and reenact what
nick was hearing we're gonna see if it
sounds the same are you ready yeah here
we go
dude
i mean it's it's pretty similar dude
freaking spiders are you done
make your way down
i think i'm gonna go all the way in
these beams i can feel these beams
bending holy
there's another hole there's a hole
where is that lead
oh
wait who is that so let's take a look at
some of the footage we shot just because
i'm really curious to see how these lens
performed compared to ours we're
starting off with his lens at 50 58
looks clean looks solid definitely it's
hitting critical focus the anamorphic
effect is certainly working it looks
good looks really good my 50
basically identical i'd even argue that
my 50 is actually a little sharper now
let's go to the 30s here this is my 30
and it's really bad it does not match if
i was trying to make a lens set i would
not put this lens in that set because it
is optically visually so far off from
the other lenses right now that like you
can't cut them together so this is his
now his lens you can definitely
instantly tell that his lens doesn't
have that bloominess to it but it's
definitely sharper and the anamorphic
effect looks like you have to get really
close to your subject to to make that
pop he's modded the lenses so that the
anamorphic bokehs stop the lens down
artificially in the sense it locks them
at about an f4 and if you're trying to
get a lot of nice shallow depth of field
and you really show off those
anamorphic-like qualities and f4 is not
really optimal because as we can see
here once we pull back a few feet we're
not getting any bokeh we're not getting
any depth of field i guess that would be
a challenge how do we keep the the
anamorphic bokeh a little larger and
wider so that way we get those that
really rich shallow depth of field let's
take a look here now we have the 85s
this is my 85 once again oh that's not
good it's blurry it's hazy my 85 is not
good
his 85 with the anamorphic mod as you
can see it's darker because it stops
down artificially but the anamorphic
bokeh is definitely working and also
it's a lot crisper he's got a better
lens the goal going into this was to
create an affordable anamorphic like
lens set it's definitely still possible
but there's something that's gonna be
holding me back here the lenses that i'm
using and working with are just not up
to snuff i got the bad ones i got the
bad lot the problem is they're
inconsistent right now i gotta find a
new 30 and a new 85 before i continue
this experiment huge thanks to blake for
bringing these by uh it was super eye
opening for me and also really exciting
seeing what you can do with so little
it's so cool seeing how it's accessible
and possible i'm really looking forward
to building this lens set up but before
i do that the hunt begins for
some good lenses
oh
wait who is that
he goes
don't go stuff in here son like i'm
serious like we thought we heard first
come on you said look that's a door
right here that's what i'm going through
there's a [ __ ] door yeah man
i'm stuck
brett how are you moving so fast
oh
brett what do you see there might be
people up here what kind of people are
you talking about something that's a lot
of people saying there might be a
squatter oh yeah god did you just what
did you just grab your pants
i did you did it
why you prepping your pants in the attic
son
oh it stinks
does it smell like a body all right as
long as confirmed we there's no people
up here then mission success i can get
out is there anyone
like we're not going to kick you out if
you are up here and we're kicking you
out for sure what are you doing what are
we doing guys you just woke me up what
are you looking for people
we were concerned there was a human up
here wait a second
what if that's what they were looking
for what if we are the people like
people right now are like what is those
people there's some people and we're
those people what if that first person
was someone who's like there's some
people up here let's get out of here
dude
let's get out of here
let's all shake ourselves
get this light in my pocket
no person is up there
okay i don't believe in ghosts i don't
believe in ghosts i like the black ooze
i wish the black ooze was actually like
a sign i was watching this segment i'm
sitting here going okay there's no
ghosts up there i got surprised i
thought it was gonna be brett i thought
brett was the reveal it was brett living
in your crawl space you guys were
looking for people and i i would say you
may have not been paying enough
attention to the evidence of people
being there brett's crawling through
carmichael is like dragging the camera
on the floor and
boom
there's cigarette butts why is there
cigarette butts who's smoking up in a
forefoot crawl space and that was and it
didn't look too old
but someone was up there before you guys
yeah what i find eerie is that what you
guys just did and some of that evidence
points to is that
those creaking sounds very well could
have been someone up there right now
it is completely within the realm of
possibility that there was someone up
there you didn't find direct evidence of
that happening when you heard the sounds
but the fact of how many people he fit
in there how much you were able to move
around and the fact that there is
evidence of other people being up there
rather recently it's possible it's
definitely possible it's totally i think
honestly just keep that ladder on hand
next time you hear that creak
deploy catch you in the air
that's the follow-up we need